wunderschönen guten abend zu viertel
nach dem schock der schlagzeilen macht
und wir haben heute brandt heiße themen
masken pflicht lauterbach expertenrat
olaf scholz und dazu gäste die werden
heute laut und heftig diskutieren davon
bin ich überzeugt wolfgang kubicki
bundestagsvize und jorge star -kolumnist
freue mich riesig und nina schenk
buchautorin und bild kolleginnen und
philipp amthor
cdu-abgeordnete und sie wissen bei führt
nach acht wurde viel und laut
insbesondere von dieser kollegen über
ein thema immer wieder diskutiert die
masken pflicht und jetzt werden sie ganz
neidisch auf ein land schauen denn da
passiert heute etwas historisches in
london da fällt in england da fällt die
masken pflicht und deswegen bevor nena
schenkt uns ihre meinung zu masten
pflicht sagt möchten einmal hin schalten
zu unserer kollegin annika rasch bild
reporterin die gerade in england in
london vor ort ist annika wie fühlt sich
das an ein leben ohne maske wir wissen
dass sie alle nicht mehr erzählt uns ein
bisschen
zu ende geht sozusagen in während
deutschland darüber dass hier an die
maßnahmen noch weiter zu verschärfen
und wieso machst gefallen sozusagen denn
man braucht im leben
einer massen mehr ich bin jetzt mal
rüber gehen durch eine mitten auf der
retweet also der einkaufsstraße von
london und sie mir in dem mich
keiner direkt am eingang zu sehen aber
man muss eine maske merkt man reingehen
kann man also ganz entspannt ohne masken
einfachen aber auch die empfehlung der
sozusagen aufgestellt worden man braucht
auch und kraft und
ich muss nicht verschweigen dass und
auch als ein reisender aus deutschland
gespielt
wenn ich ein recht ich muss gleich
machbarkeit zu machen aber das müssen
kann eben auch nicht und der grund dafür
ist vor allem zugute
mittlerweile haben ihren sechs
geschwistern ihren dritten sonst in
deutschland
und das bei gleicher intelligenz macht
man jetzt sozusagen nicht auf danke eine
der annika wir sind alle ganz neidisch
auf dich und ich wünsche dir jetzt erst
mal dass du in die kneipe gehst ohne
maske deine maske wegbricht und die
anschaust was nina schenk dazu zu sagen
hat
japan ich fliege morgen früh nach london
also ankara will follow you ich freue
mich auf ein wochenende mit einer sehr
guten freundin ohne maske also ich kann
so wenig erwarten keine masken zu tragen
dass ich morgen früh den ersten flieger
schon nach london nehme ich finde dass
die maske endlich auch in deutschland
die massen pflicht fallen muss ich habe
schon oft gefordert ich wurde sehr hart
dafür auch teilweise überall beschrieben
als crooner lügnerin als diffamierung
als sich nur diffamieren würde aber ich
bin der überzeugung die massen pflicht
muss jetzt weg england hat den freedom
day 2.0 werden noch nie in freedom day
wir hätten ihn gebrauchen wir brauchen
ihn jetzt wieder weil das größte
versagen der politik ist für mich dass
wir seit 22 jahren durchgängig die
masken pflicht haben also ich kann also
vielleicht kann mir heute abend ein
politiker wie optisch erklären findet
dabei in der partei die lange regiert
hat herr kubicki der partei die jetzt
regiert warum seit zwei jahren
durchgängig die massen pflicht gilt ich
bin dafür dass jetzt endlich die massen
pflicht feld ich habe keinen musiker für
die band ein historischer tag heute in
london in england wann fällt bei uns
endlich die maske wand werfen wir die
weg na ja ich glaube erst mal dass sie
jetzt irgendwann fallen muss die masken
pflicht ist richtig ich glaube der
zeitpunkt ist dafür jetzt noch nicht
gekommen wenn wir uns das
infektionsgeschehen angucken ich teile
deine befunden zu sagen man hat darauf
keine wirkliche lust mehr dass die
wandervereine sind uns schon wieder dass
jetzt der tag nicht da also eines gilt
wieder nicht und ländern geht alles
heran was haben sie falsch gemacht mit
ihrer fall sein
also ich glaube wir haben in der ganzen
frage der maßnahmen ist es glaube ich
ein bisschen einseitig jetzt zu sagen
man guckt man auf eine partei ist am
ende gemeinsam die level höher nein das
sage ich nicht die länder haben auch
freiheiten dazu
die ganze frage der masken pflicht auch
zu lockern und ich glaube auch wenn wir
uns die gesellschaftliche erwartung
angucken wird das jetzt auch visionen
seien die aufwand bekommt ich werde
jetzt hier keinen tag nennen am ende
heißt es ja auch immer wir sollen dann
nicht hinter unsere versprechen wieder
zurückfallen da guckt bild ja auch genau
hin ob jemand der jetzt mit regiert ist
wolfgang kubicki herr kubicki sie habe
ich mal besucht in strande da haben wir
über ihre stammkneipe diskutiert was
sagt die stammkneipe zu machen
vielleicht hat er verteile folgen die
öffentliche äußerung von mirja
heizgebläse erwachen aber da gibt es
auch passende wandel der eine private
stammt anleitung ist die masse nicht das
geringste problem weil wenn wir am tisch
sitzen tragen wir keine maske tragen wir
nur beim betreten des restaurants und
auch sozusagen der öffentlichkeit
besteht keine masten pflichtig das ist
für mich ist das geringste problem ich
glaube wir müssen mit anderen massnahmen
anfangen zweig plus in restaurants macht
überhaupt keinen sinn weil wir ja gm
steht vor giften schützen oder geben
zuvor gebucht hat mit umgekehrt schützen
denn das dürfen wir momentan hinter den
restaurants kann hinein die nicht
nachgewiesen dass ich eben von sind
zweig einzahlen macht keinen sinn weil
wir festgestellt haben und zwar
definitiv
dass wir im einzelhandel bei den
lebensmittelgeschäften keinen
infektionsgeschehen hatten und das
gleiche gilt jetzt selbstverständlich
für bekleidungsgeschäft und andere dinge
mehr das ist das erste was passieren
muss und ich glaube dass wir uns über
die frage der masten vielleicht in drei
wochen nicht wirklich unterhalten werden
denn das was großbritannien auch
dänemark das land in dem ich sehr nahe
stehen wir auch keine masten pflicht
mehr am ersten februar was die machen
liegt daran dass die omikron bälle über
sie zwei bis drei wochen vor hinweg
gerollt ist sie machen das jetzt weil
das heißt drei wochen fällt die
meisterpflicht bei uns ob sie fällt weiß
ich nicht aber sie wird immer weniger
sinnvoll an sie werden trotzdem mehr
läden dafür die werden trotzdem mein
leben nein ich bin dafür dass sie dann
auch aufgehoben würden
frühestens in drei wochen aber natürlich
darf uns werden sie erleben darunter ist
das schon mal dass viele daran dass
viele menschen die maske weitertragen
werden vor allen dingen im winter weil
sie festgestellt was ja auch völlig in
ordnung dass 27 ich halte das auch
machen ich bin ich in berlin der u-bahn
fahre dann hat sie mit bei mir die
wirklich der eindruck verfestigt es mal
wirklich sind das gesicht tragen vor
allen dingen weil wir noch andere
infektionsgeschehen haben nicht nur
krone an ich finde mich auch völlig
freiwillig das entscheiden dreieinhalb
wochen nach der mikrowelle wäre dass man
muss ja eine sache sagen ob philipp
anderes angesprochen sondern hat das
schon mal da gibt es den freedom day und
alles weg dänemark auch und dann kann
der arzt eine ganz eigene agenda der ist
in größter not da jetzt stolpert von
einer aufgeflogenen party in die nächste
und muss an sein amt kämpfen natürlich
weh dass ich auch mit irgendwas beliebt
machen die masken pflicht ich erinnere
mich noch als die gekommen ist hat
selbst herrn lila vom rk ii gesagt die
nützt gar nichts erinnert ihr euch noch
so hat das mal angefangen ich heute als
brillenträger hasse masken weil jedes
land bei diesem winterwetter ein
geschäft betreten kann ich in den ersten
in der ersten viertelstunde die waren
nicht erkennen ich gerne kaufen würde
weil die brille beschlagen also es ist
grauenhaft sieht das nicht aber ja da
schnappe arten modell jedenfalls ich
glaube aber umgekehrt muss ich sagen
realistisch den deutschen ist jetzt in
den zwei jahren so viel angst eingeredet
worden dass vor allem ältere frauen in
fünf jahren noch masken tragen werden
und dass das in deutschland das letzte
sein wird das feld da bin ich mir
ziemlich sicher obwohl die
freiheitspartei von herrn kubicki so hat
man den ball
verliert in der opposition noch nicht
mehr so viel von übrig gerade die ode
die intelligenz ist halt immer in der
minderheit und auch die freiheit hat in
deutschland nicht unbedingt eine
mehrheit das haben wir letzten zwei
jahren gemerkt ich halte viel sehr mutig
was er gesagt hat in drei wochen ist das
weg ich kann es nicht ganz glauben weil
ich kann mir schon alle vorstellen die
da unterwegs sind angefangen von herrn
lauterbach sofern er dann noch im amt
ist kommen wir später zu einer hand
kommen wir später also wir haben aus der
eso forscher mittlerweile die erkenntnis
dass masten im freien gar keinen sinn
machen sich nicht anstecken darum außer
man muss sich ab dass hier gerade
gesehen habe zwischen amt und anderen
netten gästen hier sind dann kann man
sich anstecken aber sonst noch fragen
soll nahezu unmöglich
denn so also normalerweise wie es ist
weil da wird ja auch wir drüber
gesprochen geht man sich wieder die hand
oder macht man immer noch dieses absurde
hier und da sind wir denn da brauchen
wir ihn am korpus nein ich frage
frage also also haben sie überraschende
themen oder die schützen sind wieder die
hand ich bin da ehrlicher weise
überwiegend heute aber ein paar hände
geschüttelt überwiegend bin ich immer
noch bei der bei der korona faust ich
nehme aber auch war muss ich schon sagen
wahlkreis gilt ja schon teilweise als
sehr distanziert wenn man es macht also
ich habe persönlich auch kein problem
mit hand geben wenn man sich besser
kennen sie ja doch keine magen und doch
gerade engagieren ich habe ich gesagt
hab ich gesagt wäre sogar ein auto jetzt
also
küsschen links küsschen rechts sehen was
habe ich mir auch schon aufgedrängt ja
ich mache alles andere ich hab schon
schlimmere die hier also das sage du wir
sind zwei erwachsene menschen die sich
übrigens was früher normal war war war
schnell zum hallo sagen habe ich in so
normal also ich sage vielen küsschen
links küsschen rechts ich finde das auch
mache ich immer so habe ich übrigens
heute auch mit uli wir
neiden
alles gar nicht
doch zwei erwachsenen menschen gemeinsam
entscheiden die sie sich begriff so
lohnt wird es wieder benutzt ja der herr
am tor der busse da wir sollten uns
daran gewöhnt blöden vollste uns wieder
abzutrainieren und die hände zu waschen
und man muss auch sagen da sind die
lassen dieses beispiel wenn man dann ich
mache schon bei journalisten oft aus
sicherheit sag ich mal weil ich habe
ganz unterschiedliche reaktionen in
händels portemonnaie clown einig war ein
ich mag es manchmal dann tatsächlich so
dass ich dann die hand entgegenstrecken
und mir dann von manchen litanei anhören
es sei doch noch corona das ist doch
jetzt
bei uns dieses ungewöhnlichen stehen
scheinen sich die hand zu geben begrüßen
sie mit einem kopfnicken mit einem
fröhlichen moin und dann hat das auch
noch einmal kurz zurück zu dem was man
frank kubicki gesagt ja gesagt in drei
wochen fällt die masken pflicht erste
teil der regierung es ermutige als sie
jetzt haben sie doch mal was soll denn
die meisten haben uns also das
entscheidet die regierung ja nicht
alleine die frage masken pflicht ihre
ministerpräsidenten die sich immer noch
als team hart und ihr team wollen
also am ende im wirtschafts in der mpk
diskutiert wenn ich glaube aber auch
einst die masken pflicht sinnvollerweise
sehen wir auch an dem beispiel in
dänemark und großbritannien die kann man
ja nicht isoliert diskutieren also es
ist jetzt ja auch nicht so dass der
freedom day sozusagen nur eine maßnahme
betrifft sondern es dann maßnahmenbündel
wir müssen uns darüber unterhalten auch
zeitlich gestanden so zu sagen da
einzelne maßnahmen fallen nur masken
pflicht isoliert zu diskutieren ergibt
ja wenig zu sprechen viele male an und
bevor wir weiter über karl lauterbach
diskutieren wollen wir noch einmal
sehen und hören was in england los ist
ein historischer tag dort die maske
fällt und annika ist immer noch vor ort
annika erzählt uns mal gehen die
menschen denn heute besonders in die
geschäfte und sagen maske herunter jetzt
wieder rein
ja ich war tatsächlich schon vor zwei
monaten in der weihnachtszeit backen
relativ viel los aber weniger als sonst
und gerade heute auch gegen abend merkt
man das jetzt auch die leute nach der
arbeit die geschäfte strömen wir können
jetzt noch einmal beträge dann sehen wir
auch hier ein geschäft und familie wo
auch die menschen keine maske tragen
müssen und hat man auch
die eigenverantwortung setzt der
bürgermeister hat gesagt du so ein ding
also mach das nicht gut dass nicht wie
man selbst also so ein bisschen auf den
schwierigen weg gehen wir auch immer bei
bild verfolgt haben und man muss auch
wirklich sagen die menschen haben ihr
hab gesehen und genießen das jetzt
wieder ein bisschen freier atmen kann
ich ja eine frage noch unser star
kolumnistin jörges hat gesagt es könnte
ein bisschen damit zu tun haben dass
boris johnson ein anderes thema setzen
will weil er ja so ein bisschen in der
bredouille ist es dass auch das gefühl
das ist auf jeden fall
aber was sonst immer auf uhr eingeläutet
durch die opfer schnell wie also er
wollte sagte ich den leuten oder den
menschen und den medien etwas zu werfen
die sich sozusagen das die hessen
konnten wird ein rotes fleisch und das
nicht nutzen sagen auf eine anderes
klima konzentrieren und nicht auf das
hartgeld dass sie vielleicht zum schluss
bringen könnte in den nächsten tagen
annika ich sagt prost schiers nach
england und dir einen schönen abend
wären england über boris johnson
diskutiert diskutiert deutschland
weiterhin vor allem über eigenmann und
der heißt karl lauterbach und uwe
jürgens hat sich in den vergangenen
monaten viel mit carlotta mit
wechselnden ergebnissen muss ich sagen
aber im moment ist mein ergebnis sehr
schlecht ich glaube karl lauterbach
erholt sich in meinem ansehen nicht mehr
ich finde wir müssen uns intensiv
beschäftigen mit der frage der das des
status der
genesenen
deren dauer auf drei monate verkürzt
worden ist von sechs monaten halbiert
worden es ich glaube die diskussion geht
darüber öffentlich geführt worden ist es
immer noch nicht am richtigen punkt und
es wird zeit das zu tun das will ich mal
versuchen diese
überfallartige entscheidung hat schweren
schaden verursacht und zwar
auch für den bundestag im übrigen der
jetzt aufgefordert wird das
nachzuvollziehen was für die genesenen
in der bevölkerung verhängt worden ist
nämlich von sechs auf drei monate zu
verkürzen es noch nicht passiert der
bundestag hinkte hinterher das bekommt
seinem ansehen nicht aber zunächst mal
geht es um die genesenen die genesenen
sind von einem tag auf den anderen aus
ihrem leben rausgeworfen worden denn sie
können nicht mehr irgendwo einfach in
ein restaurant gehen in einem café in
ein sportclub in ein geschäft in ein
fußballstadion in ein kino alles
unmöglich geworden von einem tag auf den
anderen und die sind wenn man so will
inzwischen genauso verfilmt wie die
ungeimpften zu denen sind sie in die
ecke geschoben worden und das von einem
staat der so
obrigkeitsstaatlich kalt daherkommt und
es ihnen nicht mal richtig erklärt
sondern sie sehen vor den latz knallt
und wenn man sich die erklärung durch
liest die dazu veröffentlicht worden ist
dann muss ich sagen das liest sich wie
eine technische anleitung zum gebrauch
von spezialschrauben ja das ist nicht
besser es geht aber ums leben von
millionen menschen
und nun haben wir ja gelernt in den
letzten monaten dass die parlamente
wieder entscheiden sollen was einer
krone politik passiert das ist aber in
diesem fall gar nicht so sein im
gegenteil nun sind die parlamente und
die parlamentarier selbst zu opfern der
korona politik geworden denn die müssen
sich gegen den eindruck zur wehr setzen
sie hätten sich ein sonderrecht
verschafft weil bei denen gilt noch
sechs monate die haben sich aber gar
kein sonderrecht verschafft da gilt das
weiter was bisher gegolten hat zunächst
mal und die sind überfahren worden wie
alle anderen auch also stehen an der
wand und überlegen sich was sie jetzt
tun sollen und sie sind nicht über
verantworten vom robert-koch-institut
was so gemeinhin behauptet wird auch von
herrn lauterbach sie sind von herrn
lauterbach überfahren worden das robert
koch institut sagt ja selbst das
ministerium das gesundheitsministerium
sei einbezogen gewesen in die geschichte
das ist noch eine sehr harmlose
formulierung ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass karl lauterbach das
losgetreten hat dass er das wollte denn
er
will dafür sorgen dass die
genesenen das sind im moment sind
ungefähr 1,6 1,7 millionen infizierte
werden alle mal zu genesen dass die zur
impfung gezwungen werden wenn er das mit
offenem visier auf der politischen bühne
versucht hätte in berlin wer in der
koalition da bin ich sicher gescheitert
und zwar an der fdp und spätestens in
der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz jede
woche später getagt hat das wäre also
sinnlos gewesen was macht er also er
macht ein 1 1 ein ausweichmanöver
er macht die politische frage zur
wissenschaftlichen und schickt das rkw
das ist schuldiger das muss ich noch zu
ende bringen sind ein paar wichtige
sense das ist aber sie haben nicht mehr
so viel
das ist das muss man schon nehmen das
ist dass ihre haare das erste böse foul
innerhalb dieser koalition das erste
böse von normalerweise wird bei seiner
blutgrätsche eine karte gezogen auf dem
fußballplatz das ist gelb oder rot und
das müsste eigentlich jetzt olaf scholz
tun aber uns bleibt die frage ob die
politik nicht jetzt veranlasst es diesen
irrsinn zurückzudrehen also wieder zu
sechs monaten zu kommen für alle die das
die eu kommission für ganz europa
vorschlägt und wie es inzwischen auch
markus söder gefordert hat müsste dann
nicht fragt man sich müsste dann nicht
karl lauterbach zurückgetreten dann
frage ich inzwischen wäre das ein
schaden ich glaube nicht wolfgang
kubicki wie sehr viel gefoult sie haben
ja auch eine kleine geschichte mit karl
lauterbach gab es mal einen kleinen
streit um die äußerungen und dann haben
sie wieder vertragen jain sie auch
darauf wie wir pflegen tatsächlich eine
sehr gerne sehr
respektvolle diskussionskultur
untereinander ich will auch sagen karl
lauterbach ist keiner der willkürliche
maßnahmen zwerg setzt um um uns zu
ärgern sondern den treibt einfach die
sorge um dass er überrannt werden könnte
von der krone entwicklung und er geht
jetzt nicht nur als der den talkshows
aufgetreten ist und als der macher aber
in der tat ist es so dass niemand davon
unterrichtet war und bin ich gewusst
hätte zwei donnerstagabend als wir die
die verordnung geändert wenn ich gewusst
hätte dass wir es dem rk überlassen
massiven grundrechtseingriff bestimmten
ergreifen durch eine mitteilung auf der
webseite ins werk zu setzen hätte ich
dem gesetz nicht zugestimmt wie viele
andere dinge und kann so etwas passieren
die im rahmen des politbetriebs wie kann
so etwas passieren ja wie kann so etwas
passieren indem also
unterstellen wir es gab schon
donnerstagabend absicht das freitagabend
zu machen der bundesrat am freitag noch
zugestimmt denen ist es auch nicht
mitgeteilt worden ich kann mich nur an
der saison oft gesagt hat wir fühlen uns
alle getäuscht es wurde lange reden
gehalten über die notwendigkeit dass die
wissenschaft künftig entscheiden soll
und nicht mehr die politik ja ist ja
geil dass ich war noch dabei also auch
die union hat ja hat ja dafür gestimmt
und ich dagegen gestimmt warum weil die
verordnung nicht für die verkürzung des
genesenen status war ja nicht ich sehe
jetzt hat die konsequente folge war ja
das wäre es ärger in die lage versetzt
haben schlicht und ergreifend durch
normale verlautbarung eine solche
maßnahme nur diesen kommunikation wenn
das der jens spahn gemacht hätte da wäre
hier aber da wäre himmel und hölle
hätten der antritt meinung von holy
ghost ich finde ich zumindest die
kommunikation ist eine katastrophe auch
auf dem die tatsache selbst schon eine
katastrophe wir hatten weil die gramm
sache zum einen aber was mich auch
ärgert als bundestagsabgeordneter ist
dass sich alle hinstellen und sagen die
debatte über die korona politik soll
nicht in der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz geführt
werden sondern in den bundestag also
unbedingt tragen ja aber man muss ja mal
sagen der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
ist ja immerhin noch mal mehr gewesen
als irgendwie hinterzimmer des ärgers
die ministerpräsidenten und die
bundestagsabgeordneten erfahren dass
alles aus der presse aber da finde ich
schon
das halte ich für neben gleicher ich
finde daher schon daher gravierende
haben dass verschiedene der politik gern
es geht um die substanz ihr glaubt doch
wohl nicht im ernst dass eine
nachgeordnete behörde eine entscheidung
von solcher tragweite selbst trifft die
millionen von genesenen in die ecke
stellt niemals das hat er die
geschäftsgrundlage wenn man ändert sich
dabei heraus damit haben wir alle in
lenherr wähler sein was denken würde
hätte er natürlich immer im ministerium
nachgefragt und kein staatssekretär
traut sich das zu entscheiden der geht
zum minister auch der minister war in
diesem fall da bin ich mir sicher weil
das war so ein gravierender einschnitt
würde sagt macht das wohl ihrer
mitmenschen haben wir unsere zusagen man
das tier lauterbach taliban jahrhundert
erklärt er wusste es nicht hier damit
der eine dann würde er lügen wenn du
sagst du weißt ja ich glaube inzwischen
dass karl lauterbach ist mit der
wahrheit nicht immer genau nimmt und in
diesem fall auch nicht er bestreitet
dass er das war und ich glaube er war es
ich glaube ihm das nicht mehr und ich
würde noch mal ich glaub mir kommen das
sagte er bei der wirklich nicht weiter
wenn er wechselweise in alle rollen ich
finde ich mir nochmal unterschätzt wir
werden das aufklären wir haben zu dem
thema eine kleine anfrage der linken das
ist auch aufgabe der opposition es ist
nicht so ich gehe nicht hin da hier
glaube ich legen derzeit horizontal
wissen und da wir zwei menschen aus der
politik hier haben und zwar keine
unbedeutende mich interessiert die frage
ob sie beide dafür sind dass diese
entscheidung rückgängig gemacht und das
ist wieder auf sechs monate geht dann
möchte ich gerne klare aussage haben und
zwar bundestag wie für die bevölkerung
mobilisieren für mich für mich ja ich
habe schon gesagt ist für mich völlig
unverständlich wie die bundesregierung
auf der einen seite durchs
gesundheitsministerium den genesenen
status bei uns auf drei monate
reduzieren kann und die auf eu ebene mit
zustimmung der bundesregierung die
genesenen status bei sechs monaten
verbleibt die schweizer sind ja schon
bei zwölf monaten übrigens auch mit
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse war
keine politische entscheidung sondern es
stand im raum dass vielleicht sogar auf
ein jahr auszudehnen man sich darauf
geeinigt dass bei sechs monaten zu
belassen ist ja schon so und ich finds
ziemlich komisch dass ich jetzt als
deutscher mit meinem genesenen status in
die in der spanien fahren kann aber mit
dem gleichen status nicht zurückkommen
wie macht man denn das jetzt politisch
weit werner nicht gar zurückzunehmen
philipp am tor hat sich noch nicht an
die oppositionsrolle doch noch
mai warten weil ich gerade sagen für
kohäsion es ist doch ganz einfach sicher
wir werden jedenfalls erstens opposition
heißt nicht einfach nur draufzuhauen
nachdenken gläubigen machen war es auch
in einer kleinen anfrage wenn man es auf
arbeiten in einer sache finde ich es
spricht wenig dafür dass wir in europa
eine sonderrolle spielen bei dem thema
ich finde wir müssen jetzt im ersten
schritt erst mal korrigieren dass
bundestag und die normalbevölkerung dann
der stelle angeglichen werden dass eine
echte sauerei regen sich die leute zu
recht darüber auf und ich finde wir
müssen ja dann auch darüber dann noch
einmal aber da ist ich bin ja auch vize
des bundestags noch einmal der bundestag
hält sich an die korona regeln des
landes berlin und dem land berlin geht
nach wie vor in der korona verordnung
der genesene status sechs monate nach
wie vor hin dass kann ich kenne ja die
fälle aus der eigenen fraktion habe ich
einen kollegen der mit johnson johnson
geimpft ist und dann diese konstellation
erlebt dass der dann jetzt noch ein
schnelltest machen muss vor dem
ausschuss anders als alle anderen das
ist auch okay ich meine der lamentierte
auch nicht drüber aber das ist natürlich
eine situation die viele bürger im land
zurecht irgendwie ärgert dass ich da von
null auf gleich der status ändert also
generika auf 6 ja ich glaube dafür
spricht einiges die diskussion
aufzufangen und das europaweit
einheitlich zu regeln weil genau der
beschriebene fall warum soll irgendwo in
spanien der genesenden status länger
anhalten als in deutschland ag
tatsächlich davon der kollege also herr
wetzel einer schöne immunologen in
deutschland hat gerade erklärt es macht
immunologisch gar keinen sinn eine
unterscheidung zu treffen zwischen den
chinesen und die geimpften und dass man
auch mit doppelt impfungen booster
infektiös sein kann das hat ricarda lang
gerade dokumentierte gestern im
bundestag eine rede gehalten hat und
wissen dass sie infiziert ist aber
gewusst hat dass frau die
grünen-vorsitzende werden will das kann
man ja klar ist das kann das kann man ja
nicht verbergen doch für die nicht erst
die und wissen infiziert war und dann
für die impfpflicht eingetreten ist und
heute erkennen muss dass ihr diese
impfpflicht gar nicht weiterhelfen würde
weil es ihr ebenfalls als geburtstag des
inspector nicht gar nicht bestätigen
auch doppelt haben wir gestern noch
einmal noch immer einen politischen
gedanken wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen
auch nach zwei jahren kroner wieder
politisch zu denken ja und das
naheliegende zu erkennen stellen wir uns
mal vorher wiler hätte das
selbstherrlich verkündet der minister
war ist es nicht und und der
bundeskanzler stellt gibt ja noch die
möglichkeit ist wurde ans
gesundheitsministerium weitergegeben und
dort nicht an herrn lautern haben wir
drei freitags
und schuhe und eine staatssekretärin
dann sind doch mindestens einer von den
dreien ist fällt es indes wenn nicht
sogar alle drei partie einen wussten es
nicht der als selbstherrlich entschieden
und hätte es klare klar vor davon liga
gerade was soll zurücktreten können nein
noch nicht also immer noch
einige fragen zu geben ja genug selbst
erstellen er gelogen hat müssen wir das
weiter aufarbeiten und ich finde er hat
sich und ernähre sehr stark so ist das
wenn der renner wenn er die in die
ministerpräsidenten hinters licht
geführt und uns auch ja was ich nicht
glaube wir sind noch immer bei aller
distanz über eine sensibel wiederhaben
carlotta war es keiner der der bösartig
auf die unterwegs ist vielleicht etwas
überarbeitet
aber nochmals anders
aus das ist der expertenrat bzw die
tatsache dass man von dem nicht mehr so
viel gehört hat die also bei einer
solchen frage wo es darum geht das
betrifft ja mehrere million menschen und
ist europaweit einmalig bei einer
solchen frage wo es darum geht zu fragen
gibt's tatsächlich ist die
wissenschaftliche evidenz für eine
solche maßnahme dafür ist der
expertenrat gebildet worden und dann
frage ich mich wenn eine solche
entscheidung getroffen werden soll
vielleicht wird im expertenrat hier an
dann würde ich dort im expertenrat mal
ein bisschen nachfragen was ich alle
davon halten und mich nicht darauf
verlassen dass die studie nahe von denen
ich bin jurist wie sie es nun kein
mediziner aber dem logischen denken dazu
geneigt die vom rk ii ran gebende
studien geben die entscheidung nicht her
damit kann man sie nicht begründen und
wie gesagt es gibt die überlegung dass
man nach drei monaten schon wieder
infektiös sein kann das stimmt aber es
geht für die künftigen gleicher weise
und das war auch vorher schon so
sehr richtig und es ist auch eine sehr
interessante spur in der frage was hier
passiert ist also wenn man das vorhat
den genesenen status so dramatisch zu
verkürzen und kann hat einen expertenrat
dem der chef des rk angehört dann kann
man doch von dem lkw chef erwarten dass
er die kollegen dort im expertenrat
fragt bevor er entscheidet und new york
ist treffender kann man von der
regierung der ich angehöre auch erwarten
dass sie auf europäischer ebene wird die
sechs erinnerte in der frage geben sie
sagt zu recht sie gehören der
regierungen an manchmal merkt man das
nicht so ganz aber doch gingen im
gegensatz zur union sind ja keine kenne
keine organisation wo wir wo einer
befiehlt
sie war die große panzerfaust kratie
besteht darin dass gerade unsere eigene
warnung kam zu einem
ganz kurz gefragt weil man nach olaf
scholz weiß olaf scholz da kommen wir
also man kann hier aber ganz
gerne regierung an der expertenrat wurde
ja von ihrer regierung mit eingesetzt
aber ich sonst christian lindner haben
sie denn mal angerufen und gefragt wurde
christa experten in kristalliner ja wir
haben darüber gesprochen
der war genauso überrascht wie ich erst
mal vorher freundlich zu formulieren und
vor allem vize vizekanzler oder vor
einigen war überrascht davon dass
deutschland gleichzeitig im eigenen land
die genese des staates auf drei monate
reduziert und europa im gleichen tag auf
europäischer ebene dafür stimmt das aber
sechs monaten bleibt also dieser diese
diskrepanz muss wie es auch
aufklärungsbedürftige wusste das
auswärtige habe ich was ist nun das
ministerium macht und um in der
nähe der armut leiden viele neue
verankern die die regierung die
wiesbaden ist noch beim boarding es wie
bei allen neuen ist er in die abteilung
werden umgesetzt hat sehr gespannt auf
die 105
sie für das alter ist bis märz man sagt
immer 100 tage ist so dass man sich
einrichten kann wir
sind ja nicht so ganz zufrieden hatte
noch beim boarding oder biologisch aber
danach nachdem wir zwei jahre cars
politiker und angela
merkel verkürzung des gelesenen sterne
hin dass die ersten aber doch
art und weise politik und wenn ich merke
wie der glänzende jens spahn im dezember
letzten jahres ende jedoch der feste und
die
wand gespielt nicht also er mich fragt
gerade was wirklich es bürgern ist für
mich fast wenn ihr dann auch so im
bundestag sitzt diskutiert ihr dann mehr
darüber ob jetzt entspannt blöder war
oder angela merkel wolfgang kuck mal so
eine einheit eher vor gericht war für
mich wenn ich höre dass die regierung
die eigentlich auch nicht richtig dass
es mit dem genesenen start ist vorher
wusste ich schockiert das ganze das
heißt eigentlich ist es eine frage herr
kubicki kann es sein dass morgen wieder
irgendeine regel beschlossen wird die
vielleicht ja auch wirklich der vize
vizekanzler christa länder gar nicht gut
finde auch gar nicht weiß ist ein
riesiges thema büro ja das wird nun so
nicht sagen aber es lohnt sich genauer
hinzuschauen
haben bei aller liebe ich finde es ganz
toll dass ich ihre oppositionsrolle
abend im greenpoint heute auch ich hab
sie nicht gefunden
denn finden wollen also ist auch in
ordnung nur noch einmal wie vor es hat
sich den letzten zwei jahren unter
cdu-führung soviel eingeschlichen an
mangelnder parlamentarischer beteiligung
an mangelnder der information und dass
von heute auf morgen weg zu schieben war
dauert ein bisschen sie müssen sie
müssen aber erst
in den ministerien aber erstmal in den
ministerien aber es mal wieder anderes
bewusstsein dafür schärfen dass die
auskunftspflicht über abgeordneten und
sie nicht wir ja für ein
weiteres beispiel dafür wie diese
parlamentarische demokratie in diesen
letzten zwei jahren eingeschläfert
wissen das genau das ist doch ein ganz
dicker klops der hier passiert worden
ist und das ist nicht irgendwas zwischen
zwei ministerien sondern sie millionen
menschen von betroffenen und zutiefst in
ihrem leben absolut keiner ruft skandal
keiner ruft das wird sofort rückgängig
gemacht der kanzler ist gar nicht zu
hören zudem habe ich aber das aber nicht
nur der kanzler auch sonst ist niemand
zu hören man dort ganz sanft miteinander
um bloß den karl lauterbach nicht
bestätigen
nicht mal haben wir nicht so leicht
fester werden nur hamm keinen mehrwert
das hat rein hab ich zeit darauf
hinweise dass ich in einem blatt was
dieser sendung sehr nahe steht erklärt
habe das ist für mich sinnvoll erscheint
die chinesisch als sechs monate
anzuheben oder aus der bundesliga packen
und deiner anderen also ich muss mal
eins sagen wenn ich über die politik
rede ist wolfgang kubicki immer
ausgenommen das will ich jetzt ja mit
eigenen verstand durchs leben geht und
dass auch immer wieder zu erkennen gibt
da schaltet das ist das wunderbare ist
jetzt mein karriereende was gerade
eine einem fall glauben sie dass das
karl lauterbach popularität am ende des
jahres da liegt wo jens spahn
popularität heute liegt nein weil im
gegensatz zu jens spahn karl lauterbach
tatsächlich nicht nur lernfähig ist und
auch reflektiert jens spahn war gefangen
im politischen bach konstruktionen karl
lauterbach hat zwei dinge in seinem
herzen und ich kann wieder einmal ist
der wissenschaftler tatsächlich und zum
anderen und zum anderen war auch in
seine eigene fraktion früher weshalb
viele von den kollegen kollegen gesagt
packen können sie verstehen also dass
jemand der einem auf den geist geht
nicht das kann ich mir schon legen wir
sehr auf den geist ich bin die
jahresarbeit noch ein ich mache das ja
nicht böse es gibt leute da sagt man
jetzt aber schluss wird genau was
trinken und müssen nicht dauernd über
die gleiche thematik reden aber ich bin
sicher dass er
seine eigene innere sorge berlin wird
dass er alles böse von den menschen ab
halten muss ich bin sicher der wird in
seiner rolle als gesundheitsminister
richtig gut hinein beraten wird und er
ich weiß dass ich gar nicht leiden
können dann wird die frage deshalb
politik machen als die einzigen
schwester ist keine frage des leiters
der minister wird auch das sehen wird
doch der wird er jeden tag schwächer er
hat relativ klar angefangen das sehe ich
nur hat sich im ton zurück genommen er
hat sich ähnlich verhalten wie der
kanzler auch der hat nicht weiter angst
verbreitet im volk so und jetzt sehen
wir dass rutscht immer weiter vom blech
und was passiert mit dem man wenn die
politik also das parlament jetzt
beschließt die halbierung des des
genesenen status zurückzunehmen gegen
seine ausdrückliche empfehlung er hat ja
gerade taufrisch gesagt er will das
nicht er hat auch bestritten dass er
davon wusste erstaunlicherweise er will
das nicht und dann entscheidet die
politik gegen ihn was macht man da als
minister da bleibt man und sagt das ist
halt so eine parlamentarische demokratie
die haben ja gerade die hosen
runtergezogen aber ich bin auch so noch
schön
ja wirklich dass ich jetzt hier
eingeladen rücktritt also dass das jetzt
hier eingeladen wurde um carlotta waren
ein voller breite zu verteidigen
müsste man kann heute war selbst
einladen und der war
sonntag ist am sonntag zu gast bei die
richtigen der wunderbar und der wird
jetzt im zweifel auch ordentlich
erklären auch da bin ich mir sicher wenn
karl lauterbach zu anderen
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnis kommen
wissenschaft ist ja dauernd im flow dann
ist ja auch manns genug definitiv
zusagen die entscheidung nehmen wir
zurück und nach der werbung darstellt
und wir vielleicht auch wieder über karl
lauterbach aber nicht nur unter anderem
über die frage wo steckt eigentlich der
kanzler wo ist olaf scholz gleich nach
der berg
[Musik]
also da kann ich ein lauterbach und
nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren zurück viertel nach acht
gegentoren der schlagend sein machen
mein name ist relativ
so nicht
herr jörges retten
aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der darin führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und um die füße russ und die ratten das
thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur der
ard zu überlassen lasst den leuten noch
mal den spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu führen
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig gut
auch das übrige andrack träger aus in
bewegung bringen ich habe meinen beitrag
um eine sache immer bekommt wer kümmert
sich darum niemand gibt es viele man
muss ganz klar auch darüber sprechen
dass man nicht wirklich richtig ist die
komödie nicht mehr glauben nur noch vier
tore
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück führten im
talk der schlagzeilen macht und hier
wurde auch in der werbepause ein bisserl
weiter diskutiert aber philipp amthor
fragt sich wo oder stolz ist ja das ist
in der tat eine frage die sich dieser
tage aufdrängt wo ist eigentlich olaf
scholz in den vielen debatten die wir im
parlament führen ist zwar körperlich
anwesend aber er äußert sich nicht in
der debatte um die impfpflicht kein
gesetzentwurf und besonders frappierend
heute in zur lage in der es ist für ihn
okay eine regierungserklärung kein wort
es wird debattiert über das programm
wird den deutschen g7 präsidentschaft
kein wort von olaf schau haben soll die
werbung schon zu ende ich finde es ist
nicht die werbung die hier zu ende ist
und dann ist ein ernsthaftes thema und
ich finde als vizepräsident des
parlaments könnte ihnen auch am herzen
liegen dass der bundeskanzler auch in
der mitte des parlaments debattiert die
lage in der ukraine
da schauen alle auf deutschland alle
fragen sich wie positioniert sich
deutschland in dieser lage es brauchte
cdu und csu um diese debatte zu
beantragen friedrich merz hat heute eine
gute rede gehalten führung gezeigt vom
bundeskanzler hören wir im parlament
nichts und ich erwarte dass er im
parlament dazu stellung bezieht und sich
nicht wegduckt und deswegen ist die
frage wo es olaf scholz die berechtigte
frage uli hoeneß weiß wohl auf scholz
ist oder urlaubsausgaben moment auch
international unterwegs und zwar gerade
in der frage sollen kalorien seien auch
soldaten lernen ich habe mir gestern
diese debatte orientierungs debatte über
die impfpflicht angehört das ist den
deutschen noch ein stückchen näher als
die ukraine lage ja da wo nachts doch
aber noch mehr um nebenthema moment nein
das macht es nicht ich will das noch mal
zurückgeben und da habe ich mir angucke
wer redet da eigentlich und wenn
wolfgang kubicki nicht derjenige gewesen
wäre der als der als stellvertretender
parteivorsitzender dort eine rede
gehalten welt zu sein antrag den
werbeblocker der cdu oder satz war noch
nicht zu ende dann hätte außer den afc
führen kein partei- oder fraktionschef
dort eine rede gehalten und die ihr habt
alle eure gesundheitspolitiker ins
rennen geschickt bei dieser wichtigen
frage und die parteiführer und fraktions
wir haben sich alle bedeckt gehalten aus
taktischen gründen mal abwarten wie der
hase läuft aber die gesundheitspolitiker
das konnte man deutlich sinnvoller
gestern als friedrich merz exakt
friedrich versehen hat es für richtig
aber man muss natürlich märz habe sich
den schwerpunkt gesetzt in dieser woche
die ukraine und die auch den
fraktionsvorsitz zu übernehmen und ralph
brinkhaus zur seite 2 was passiert ich
halte das für eine neue spector
herausbringen dazu noch einmal die
datensätze mit 24 ja auch nicht die
opposition wann der kanzler wozu redet
sondern die regierung das war übrigens
bei angela merkel genauso gab viele
fragen irgendwas anlage stellen müssen
aber angela merkel außenpolitik hat die
kanzlerin im parlament immer
klarstellung gut dass labbadia das
nachher bratislava daran dass der
amtierende der großen koalition dazu in
der lage war ja das ist ja jetzt ganz
anders nicht als die außenministerin das
hat ja auch die union mittlerweile
erkannt macht ja im ausland und auch
hier eine respektable figur von mir aus
sogar über meine erwartungen habe hier
annalena baerbock auch schon kurz ich
hab mein bestes für uns neulich las ich
uns
schon aber er hat sich nicht gezahlt um
beim thema zu bleiben also wenn man sich
als auch in den vergangenen tagen die
medien anschaut zum beispiel die zeit
heute in einem großen essay über das was
ohne abschluss macht oder nicht macht
dann ist ja schon zu erkennen dass der
fonds so ein bisschen ist olaf scholz
will so bleiben wie vorher er kommt
nicht so richtig aus der deckung er
antwortet nicht auf fragen konkret
insbesondere in interviews er ist zeigt
kann klartext bei vielen fragen
ausweichend impfpflicht ukraine ganz
ganz viele themen herr kubicki sie sind
doch im klartext politiker erwarten sich
eigentlich auch mal dass ihr kanzler ist
es ja jetzt in ihrer koalition auf den
tisch haut und sagt da gehen wir an im
gegensatz zu ihnen habe ich ein anderes
demokratieverständnis das besteht darin
dass nicht wir einen haben der sagt wo
es lang geht sondern dass wir führung
durch überzeugung die generieren nicht
durch anordnung das unterscheidet ja
diese regierung der video von der
letzten argumente die hätten ja außerdem
kanzlerin überhaupt niemand gebraucht
sonst nach auffassung von einander hier
ist hat hier ist es so dass sich
regierung und zwar in allen ihren
facetten nach außen wahrnehmbar ist
sowohl in der ukraine krise durch einen
der berge ziemlich klaren worten nur wie
auch fröhlich merz heute eingestanden
hat in der finanzpolitik durch christian
lindner und wenn's drauf ankommt wird
der kanzler dass sein sohn aber es gibt
sehr wohl aber es gibt keinen grund zu
sagen olaf scholz will das jetzt und
deshalb passiert es so dass war 16 jahre
cdu
politikers wird das punkten die in einer
arbeitsfähigen koalition ok jörges kennt
wahrscheinlich oder hat die meisten
kanzlerinnen kanzler in den letzten
jahren intensiv begleitet für den stern
immer wieder von ganz ganz nahe wie
bewertest du olaf scholz bisheriges auf
also erstmal wollen wir uns erinnern
dass angela merkel auch immer wieder
phasen hatte wo die medien geschrieben
haben was denkt sie eigentlich wo es sie
überhaupt das ist der höchste zeit dass
ich mal dazu was hast du dich einmal
gefordert und dann das rote sofa
ich habe angela merkel ja das ist ja
immer wieder vorgehalten worden
spezifikum von medien die wollen leben
auf der bühne haben und wenn da sich
einer nicht zeigt dann sind sie
enttäuscht ich finde dass ermüdend das
haben die medien irgendwann angefangen
in einer stadt von anderen ab weil das
ist jetzt so die quelle die die die liga
beherrscht relativ viele interviews
gegeben
sind sagt aber nicht viel da ist wie
angela merkel ich fand zunächst mal
positiv das ehrt dieser hysterie welle
in der kroner politik entgegen getreten
ist wie die gesamte koalition das war
ins fordert die fdp aber auch schon aus
stolz denn wir hätten sonst schon unter
etwa die welt unter führung der cdu mit
herrn brown hätten wir längst wieder ein
lockdown gehabt und zwar um die
weihnachtszeit und zwar mit karacho weil
wir noch nicht
ganz so schwarz weiß nicht doch das ist
ein anderes thema aber dass ein
gewichtiges wieder da hat er sich groß
raus gewagt und jetzt will er sich daran
auch nicht mehr messen die sich jetzt
zeigt ist dieser kurs in sachen
impfpflicht und corona politik verkehrt
er muss drauf gucken was sein minister
treibt und der treibt ganz gute sachen
und es wird höchste so etwas setzt sogar
treten soll haben wir verstanden hat
ich höre unseren jungs da ja wirklich
auch jetzt schreien die ämter sind sie
für die impfpflicht ist die union für
die impfpflicht stimmen sie für die
musterklage oder schreien sie jetzt hier
nur um erklären
zusätzlich für die endlich ja oder nein
herr kubicki zur wahrheit gehört dass
unser stimmungsbild innerhalb der
fraktion auch unterschiedlich frag doch
sie persönlich habe eine eher skeptische
haltung mit blick auf die jetzt mal
butter bei die fische amtseid ja oder
nein ich habe dann aber ja oder nein
aber ich habe mal eine frage ja oder
nein nicht so einfach ist doch nicht die
sozialen kämpfe ich ja oder nein doch er
geht um die frage der vollzieht dass wir
als vollstrecker es geht um die frage ob
waren die frage ob sie damit sind wir
müssen dafür die eine grundlage schaffen
und vor allem müssen wir und das finde
ich ist ein richtiges ziel in der
fraktion zu einer position kommen ja ich
glaube ihr macht es euch laden zu indem
ihr werk gegeben es ist doch es ist
ich bin einfach ich glaube wenn sie
viele eine impfpflicht hinten oder shops
unterstützen wenn sie gegen einfließen
müssen sie mich unterstützen genau da
können sie sich jetzt entscheiden sind
sie für ein endlich da müssen sie doch
heute sagt sie schaltet ich sage ja
selbst gesagt wir wollen schalten also
ich finde von der sache die argumente
die sie zum beispiel gegen eine
impfpflicht vorbringen finde ich
persönlich sehr plausibel aber ich sage
auch ich gebe das ziemlich auf dass wir
in der fraktion eine einheitliche
positionierung dazu finden und das ist
auch genau das richtige und kämpfe ich
kämpfe in der fraktion für oder gegen
eine impfpflicht ich bin offen dafür
mich überzeugen zu lassen frage aber
kämpfen lohne ja ich sage jedenfalls
ohne ein impf register und ohne
praktische vorgaben wie man diese
impfpflicht vollzieht werde ich eine
höfliche nichts absätze des polit
theater sozusagen zwischen cdu und fdp
kubicki sie sind ja einer der anführer
kann man sagen der anti allgemeine
impfpflicht bewegung wenn sie ihr was
ich aber nicht voller stolz geht das
versteht nicht in der sache der dass das
steht das keinen sinn dass das weiß
glaube ich auch jeder zuschauer bei bild
sie haben ja immer klar gegen gesprochen
ihre prognose wird am ende ihre meinung
überzeugen oder die von olaf scholz und
anderen die sagen und braucht diese
pflicht
das kommt auf den zeitablauf anlagen
wird dann wirkung gesetzesvorlagen haben
bisher sind das ja nur ankündigungen von
den protagonisten einer impfpflicht ab
18 oder eine pflicht ab 50 dass es ein
gesetzentwurf geben sollte ist noch
nicht da wenn wir das ende märz
entscheiden dann wird uns die reale
entwicklung weit davon weg bringen das
die mehr des bundestages noch für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht ab 18 stimmen
würde das muss man wirklich sagen und
selbst wenn das schuldig ich glaube ich
glaube momentan ist das kräfteverhältnis
so dass heute stand heute eine mär des
hauses für eine impfpflicht 50 stimmen
würde das warme witterung
für eine allgemein heftig wird
wahrscheinlich keine mehr geben weil die
union sich ja ich verrate jetzt nicht
ihre strategie sich darauf eingelassen
dazu sagen wir brauchen erst ein im
frühling ist da sie wissen das dauert 10
mal wieder heftig das ist das dauert
zwei jahre ist eingerichtet ist und dann
stimmen der fli zu umgehen viele stimmen
zu können und damit olaf scholz zwingen
zu wollen das ja die politische
herangehen zweite zwingen zu wollen für
eine eigene mehrheit zu sorgen von der
am tor weiß dass die fdp jedenfalls
diese eigenem er nicht herstellen wird
und das ist wie ich finde der sache
nicht angemessen es geht hier wirklich
um die frage wie können wir
sinnvollerweise die menschen erstes mal
wieder erreichen und 20 uhr mit dem
panini geschehen fertig waren es war
nicht nehmen das virus ausrotten sondern
wir wirklich lernen damit zu leben aber
es gehe ihnen eine sachfrage finde ich
die wir nach unseren üblichen
regulierungen und vorstellungen aus
diskutieren können und nicht nach dem
modus jeder macht seins ich finde es
kann man der sache diskutieren und nicht
nur sozusagen nach dieser frage
orientierungs debatte was auch immer da
muss man schon sagen scholz will eine
impfpflicht hat dafür in seiner
regierung keine mehrheit und könnte
versuchen bei uns das ist jetzt viel
klein-klein beamter china das geht mir
auf den geist als angela merkel die
wollte auch die beiden wir haben wir
alle nur über eine
kurze impfpflicht ist glaubt sein bestes
verlaub bist du am ende dass die
impfpflicht kommen wird oder glaubst du
dass wolfgang kubicki sie noch erinnern
weiß die ja ich dachte armin laschet
wettkampf seit dem sack ich keine
prognosen mehr was ich aber endlich
sagen möchte ist
ganz klar in dieser runde generell auch
mal ich finde auch und da bin ich jetzt
auch mal ehrlich wenn man das so
mitbekommt denn dann denkt man sich auch
manchmal als bürger so meinen kann
eigentlich nicht mehr als ich verstehe
auch viele menschen die nicht mehr
könnte ich selbst werde manchmal
wahnsinnig selbst nicht nur eine
außengastronomie
und wenn wieder jemand sagt die freundin
die es kommen musste man schnelltest
machen wir sie noch nicht gewusst hat
ist lege ich mich schon wieder auf mein
problem ist nicht mehr aber nicht oder
nicht gut war oder ob jetzt olaf scholz
sorry philipp aber auch olaf scholz
gerade irgendwie weg ist oder ob er
wieder da ist mein problem ist dass wir
jetzt endlich mal ein lichtblick
brauchen england feier zum zweiten mal
in fremde und ich werde wieder in der
außengastronomie man booster dingen
vorzeigen müssen und ich bin auch
dagegen dass die impfpflicht kommen
deswegen ich kann dich ja jetzt
vielleicht überzeugen und einem einzigen
satz wenn du für die impfpflicht stimmst
du stimmst du auch dafür dass ein mensch
nicht über einen medizinischen eingriff
entscheiden kann und wenn dann doch ins
nebenwirkungen auftreten sollten ich
finde das geht einfach nicht die
nebenwirkungen seiten wenn nicht ich
glaube es gibt es objektive kriterien
die darüber entscheiden werden ob es die
impfpflicht geben wird oder nicht mehr
wenn die pandemie zu ende geht und es
wird eine ende mit raus und alle
maßnahmen werden zurückgenommen und die
leute können sich frei bewegen wer
wollte denn wo sie müssen also gar kein
impfschutz mehr irgendwo zeigen wer will
denn da kontrollieren ob sie jetzt
geimpft sind ja oder nein ein im krieg
ist da gibt es nicht du musst das einen
ausweis gar nicht bei dir haben meinte
da gibt da kommt noch irgendwie in
ordnungsamt in ein restaurant gestiefelt
und lässt sich von den gästen die impf
zeugen also zeit und teilhaben sie waren
dabei haben müssen ja mehr blechen
ansehen soll das machen man wartet hier
auf dieser bühne wo im moment so viele
mit mit filz latschen rumlaufen mal eine
figur sie sind es ja aber das niveau ist
das muss ins land und lässt sich noch
nicht zu ende sagte ich noch mal eine
figur die eine führungsfunktion hat die
sagte macht keinen sinn mehr das kann
auch märz sein wir machen das nicht dann
hat die koalition keine eigene mehrheit
und dann ist es geplant oder auch lea
kanzler sagt mir dass jetzt intensiv
angeguckt ich habe übrigens in der
debatte im bundestag beobachtet er hat
interessanterweise hätte merkel niemals
gemacht sogar von den akten aufgeschaut
und hat die afg redner beobachtet ihn zu
gehört also frau weiter zugehört und
auch natürlich in us open gewinner ist
also den kritikern mein eindruck ist
nicht festgelegt er sind wahrheit gar
nicht entschieden ob er das wirklich
will aber er hat sich mehrfach gesagt
hat
da hat er gedacht er bewegt sich im
breiten heißt es schwer da wieder runter
zu oder
aufgrund neuer erkenntnisse müssen auch
in der lage sein unsere haltung flexibel
alles was ich will ist bei xerox auch
richtig finde wir können nicht sagen vor
einem jahr hat er aber dieses und jenes
gesagt ich weiß nicht mehr was ich vor
einem jahr gesagt habe und daran muss
ich mich mein leben lang ist festhalten
lassen aber es gibt in der not geht das
mir sehr viel zu viel politische
spielereien mir geht es um die sache
wenn wir feststellen dass die impfung
keine fremdschutz beinhaltet das also
geimpfte und gemusterte sich nicht nur
selbst anstecken konnten auch wieder
andere anstecken können wenn wir
feststellen dass die wirkung des
impfschutzes was den selbstschutz angeht
nach drei monaten zu ende ist dann macht
eine impfpflicht keinen sinn ich werde
mir trotzdem eine vierte empfohlen weil
es mit ruhiger werden lässt in einem
etwas höheren alter fenster junge frauen
sagen als aber als mannschaft trat
genießen ich habe genug von den impfung
mittlerweile aber auch weiß impfpflicht
ist ein riesenthema und das wird ja auch
noch weiter thema sein aber es gibt noch
andere themen tatsächlich kriege ich
mich zumindest beschäftigt haben in den
vergangenen wochen war ich in der
ukraine unterwegs als reporter ich fahr
dahin schon seit 20 13 eigentlich als
damals menschen mit der europäischen
flagge demonstriert haben für freiheit
für frieden und sie sehen wladimir putin
das ist der mann der möglicherweise mit
seinen truppen wieder in die ukraine
reinmarschieren will man sieht einen
riesigen panzer auflauf an der grenze
man sieht dort menschen die große angst
haben ich habe eine frau getroffen die
gesagt hat sich will sich jetzt selbst
verteidigen sie macht kurse dort um wenn
wladimir putin putins truppen
einmarschieren wenn sie nach kiew kommen
sich verteidigen zu können ich finde es
ist eine schande wie sich deutschland
verhält ich finde es eine schande dass
sich eine verteidigungsministerin
ernsthaft hinstellt und sagt hier sind
5000 herzlichen glückwunsch ukraine ja
bitte wie soll man sich denn da
verteidigen gegen wladimir putins armee
und dass diese verteidigungsministerin
nicht mal kapiert dass sie keine ahnung
offenbar hat von außen und defensiv
politik verteidigungspolitik dann muss
ich wirklich sagen ist sie eine
fehlbesetzung unabhängig davon
sanktioniert endlich wladimir putin und
nicht nur wladimir putin sondern auch
aldi ideen unterstützt haben in den
vergangenen monaten in den vergangenen
jahren dazu gehört auch altkanzler
gerhard schröder ich fordere sanktionen
gegen gerhard schröder er ist jemand der
entscheidend dazu beigetragen hat und
das blatt die mir putin so weit hoch
kommen konnte dass er überhaupt ein nord
stream projekt durchdrücken konnte ich
finde all diejenigen die putin weiterhin
unterstützen gehören sanktioniert also
lieber paul ronzheimer ich schätze dich
ungeheuer weil du nicht nur in schützen
haben in der ukraine eine tolle rolle
spielt sondern auch in der innenpolitik
die ich sehr gut auskennt
sanktionen gegen schröder zu verlangen
ist eine kuriose forderung schröder wenn
man beobachtet was er erklärt hat in den
letzten jahren hat kein wort zu putin
gesagt keine frage beantwortet er gibt
nur noch ganz selten interviews wenn er
ganz sicher ist ja auch bei instagram
geschäfte ehefrau moment moment mit
allem möglichen aber
er hat sich auch nicht georderte nord
stream er hat sich auch nicht geäußert
zu dem aufmarsch geht ihm nicht darum
was er sich wie er sich auch äußert
sondern was er tut und dass wir hinten
dass sie dir mal ausreden darf nur
ausreden da zieht auch keine fehler
sondern er sitzt in den aufsichtsgremien
von gazprom und rosneft gazprom mafia
unter einem liefert gas jaja team von
denen leben wir und rosneft liefert
benzin und zwar den größten teil des
deutschen benzinverbrauchs der kommt aus
russland damit fahren wir autos und mit
dem gas heizen wir unsere häuser und da
hätte schon längst alternativen finden
müssen und für das wir das benzin aus
russland hat man eine weile gebraucht
aber jedenfalls hat er sich da hat sich
ja niemand beklagt darüber dass wir
russisches benzin fahren sondern und
dafür das ist seine aufgabe und dafür
wollen wir ihn bestrafen er redet nicht
für putin er redet für die energie
geredet ausschließlich für putin aber
meine frage an wolfgang kubicki was
sollten wir denn tun sind sie zufrieden
herr rony sich einfach weil ich war
lambrecht dort ich gestellt hat und 5000
helfer verteilt als hätte ich nicht
gemacht weil das projekt peinlich wirkt
ich hätte auch keine feldlazaretts
hingeschickt das werde nicht mehr selbst
in schicken sondern an käufer sieht man
dass auch peinlich was sie da gemacht
hat ja ich hätte komplett darauf
verzichtet und erklärt wir liefern wir
liefern keine waffen im juli fand keine
waffen entspannungs gebietet es die
ständige redewendung
beschlusslage seitdem ich politisch
denken kann dieser 32 jahren parlamenten
das war bisher immer so dass wir uns zu
verhalten haben und ich bin auch nicht
davon überzeugt dass waffen nicht an den
koreaner den frieden stabilisieren aber
nicht vielleicht das risiko erhöhen weil
zu glauben dass die hausfrau in kiew
sich die russische truppen verteidigen
kann wenn sie den einmarschieren ist
sowas von naiv dass ich ihnen das gar
nicht zutraue ich weiß nicht was ich
dort ja mal sehr lineare kubicki werke
dort die stimmung ja in der ukraine und
wieviel erschütterung über positionen
deutschlands wie von ihnen dort nämlich
raus kommt wo man sagt wie kann
deutschland sich eigentlich so verhalten
ja weil die gesagt wir dann nach wie vor
davon ausgehen dass das waffenlieferung
krisengebiete mit unserem
selbstverständnis nicht viel vereinbar
sind und noch einmal ich wehre mich auch
dagegen zu sagen putin ist jetzt der
ganz böse aldi in der nähe von putin
sind ganz böse das mag so sein aber er
hat ja bloß hunderte menschen in syrien
abgeschlachtet hat truppen in die
ukraine geschickt hat hier wenige
kilometer entfernt im tiergarten leute
umbringen lassen hat herr navalny
vergiftet sondern sie daran gut das war
da alles persönlich und die unsere
amerikanischen freunde mit in
afghanistan auch nur stützende maßnahmen
vorzubereiten
ich will das gar nicht vergleichen aber
sie sind gerade dabei etwas böses zu
initialisieren ohne dass sie die
möglichkeit haben gesprächsebene zu
eröffnen und konflikt dazu sage ja nicht
dass man nicht sprechen soll er also da
muss ich schon sagen ich finde so dieses
argument es ist schon ein bisschen
leicht zu sagen wir liefern keine waffen
in spannungsgebiete so ungefähr als sei
die ukraine irgend beliebiges land wir
haben hier eine klare frage auch des
verhältnisses von russland zum
völkerrecht und das verhältnis von
russland so nato und da kann ich nur
sagen das war eine peinliche nummer mit
den 5000 helm und deswegen finde ich es
umso mehr eigentlich frappierend ich mal
nicht
fahren muss jetzt wieder zurück fragen
sind sie für waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine und dann welche waffen also ich
finde jedenfalls wir sollten diesen
pauschal ausschluss nicht machen und wir
sollten grundlegend darüber diskutieren
als diese 5000 helm und wir müssen schon
robust
die ukraine wir müssen da aus meiner
sicht eine robuste politik jedenfalls an
den tag legen und ich finde da ist
führungen auch der bundesregierung
gefragt warum durch um die aufregung
natürlich ist das gefragt ich finde es
ja geradezu absurd dass es dann heißt ja
wir gucken da einfach mal ein bisschen
aber noch nicht richtig sein doch
parlamentarier der aber auch entscheiden
soll meine frage ist wollen sie waffen
liefern welche waffen also die frauen
wären sie im zweifel bereit dann auch
deutsche truppen in der ukraine zu
stationiert für den fall dass es nicht
ausreicht wir haben keine und das ist
völlig klar wir werden daher keine
isolierten aktionen machen sondern das
muss man im zusammenhang mit unseren
bündnispartnern diskutieren und ich
finde vor allem wir müssen hier dann von
der regierung die hat da auch im übrigen
das initiativrecht ja an vielen stellen
in der auswärtigen politik dann müssten
wir jetzt mal vorschläge haben olaf
scholz duckt sich weg der hat im
parlament heute die chance verstreichen
der vorschlag war ja wir liefern keine
waffen das ist der vorschlag wir liefern
keine wäre das ein bisschen wenig oder
also ich also aus der perspektive der
ukraine ist es doch ziemlich ziemlich
wenig wenn man sagt hier sind die 5000
helm und jetzt ist erstmal schluss mehr
haben wir euch nicht es gibt es gibt ja
das ist zu recht zu kritisieren länder
muss man mehr erwarten von der länder
die haben eine andere geschichte mit
russland oder der sowjetunion als
deutschland das dürfen wir nie vergessen
erstens zweitens reden wir hier über
sanktionen gegen schröder wie sollen die
denn aussehen
soll so aussehen dass er unter
hausarrest gestellt wird dass ihm das
hell müssen sauber sein handy abgenommen
herr staatsanwalt otto beschlagnahmt
wird dass er beuge haft geht bis er sich
von putin distanziert als auch glaube
ich
finde die sanktionen gegen einen
deutschen staat nein nein heute andere
härte gegenüber putin als jetzt die
sanktionen gegenüber geheim da natürlich
ein beispiel verfügen dass jemand der
für wladimir putin arbeitet und so ein
nahestehender lobbyist ist
möglicherweise ein konto eingefroren
wird ja dann bin ich dafür ja wo dann
unterhalten wir jetzt das sammelkonto
auch an bald in die ukraine wird
auch nicht es gibt ja schon unterschied
zwischen sozusagen einem start
wir leben in einem demokratischen
rechtsstaat sie können eine politische
meinung kann aber zu glauben sie können
einem deutschen staatsbürger bei ihm
seine meinung nicht passt wir konnten
ein pflicht die meinung nicht die
meinung nicht die meinung sondern ich
meine als lobbyist auftritt für wladimir
putin das tut er ja nicht doch nein er
hat seit jahren kein worten hatte putin
gesagt weil er einmal einen satz gesagt
hat lupenreiner demokrat der bitter
bereut hat seit diesem satz hat der ist
ja eher mehreren aufsichtsrat demian ja
aber da geht es ja um unsere
energieversorgung darunter alle
unabhängig davon also zusatzfunktion
laut sender das ist das ganz russland
unter putin besteht und er für alles
verantwortlich ist finde ich auch ein
bisschen komisch das wäre so als wenn
wir sagen so eine olaf scholz ist in
deutschland für alles was hier passiert
aber was soll's wieder dran waren und
der setzung für den a8 herzlichen dank
für diese hitzigen diskussion heute
abend danke
[Musik]